it's irrelevant do i mean it's like i
played sports all my life and then i you
know but i mostly get cast as like
victims
you know i know but don't you but
there's there's a thing though i think
with like sports though is if you play
organized sports there is something that
you learn in there that really isn't
talked about now because everything's
just considered like so much of sports
now is considered like male toxicity
like how you learn
how you know you learn your role where
you fit in
how to bring people up not be a negative
force you learn to how to lose how to
come back
from losing um you learn how to lead how
to learn you learn all of this amazing
stuff and so i think being captain of
the football team means you had some
sort of leadership qualities i mean
watch these [ __ ] hollywood movies and
it's just me oh he's the best looking
guy and he's a douche and he treats the
cheerleader he's dating like [ __ ] i mean
that's all written from nerds yeah who
didn't play